you look
beautiful with the tan fishnet it's I'm
loving the whole vibe it's my wolf HS
anyway congratulations baby daughter now
and and your son's
only your your son is only 10 months
he's 10 months old you got two little
ones are you
sleeping a little bit I was going to say
probably not like as soon as one CMS
down the other one they're both so calm
though both of them they don't cry
they're always happy they're so so cute
together little tip don't tell other
mothers this very lucky yeah that's
awesome that's incredible so um her name
is London right yes it's adorable
because your name is Paris that's
amazing did you always have this plan
I've been planning this name forever my
whole life I always knew I wanted a
daughter named London are you serious
yes I didn't even know I wanted
kids that's what you had like you were
one of those girls that like mapped it
out or one of those people that's
awesome yes I just kind of wing it yeah
I just hope it but you're married as
well so the last time oh my God
good I want one of those I was like
that's really beautiful oh my gosh but
you got married since the last time here
you're super happy now I'm so happy he's
just my everything he's so kind and
loyal and sweet and funny and my best
friend and my everything thank you yeah
you look beautiful that's awesome to
find like a friend yes yeah that's good
cuz I think that's what's most important
just finding someone that you can just
spend the rest of your life with and
someone who supports and lifts you up
and I've never had any man be like this
with me oh my gosh I'm so happy for you
and you have a little family now too oh
my God it's incredible you're living
your best life I like it sliving oh
you're sliving I remember that last time
no but I I love how open you are you
have a new Memoir out and I love how
open you are because I've had several
friends that had a really hard time
getting pregnant and you you discussed
that your road to Motherhood was not
easy yes doing IVF which is just
extremely difficult and hard on your
body yes mhm like emot and physically
yes it is yeah but I'm just so grateful
to have my little ones now yeah and it's
amazing too to find like a surrogate
that you trust with that job that would
be my thing I think I'm a tad bit
controlling be like what are you eating
like what are what are you doing like
why I think that which is so stupid
because I ate whatever when I was so I
think I'm harder on
[Music]
others
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home